tears ani Alison moderately minister of
petroleum resources Nigeria we've just
come out of a panel very interesting
Alabama ki-moon aware we discussed the
issue of ending energy poverty obvious
core principle that is ensuring that the
all countries we are able to provide
access to energy different types and
different forms but I wide access to
energy from everyone over a given period
of time and while our economies
subscribe to place over it in Nigeria we
are trying to get from the average five
thousand megawatt to 10 and then to
15,000 so on and so forth over a number
of years for the oil and gas sector we
are working very hard to ensure that we
have sustainable supplies and asked to
do that but while that is being put in
place as i said in the panel i think it
is very important particularly in
developing economies that we bring our
hydrocarbon resources to bear on the
real economy and the commercialization
of those resources for the people for
the country as a whole so it is critical
that we do the sort of things to take
place at this point in time the
commercialization of gas ensuring that
class begins to marry avoid stalker and
not just a few alas attachment
additionally used of the power
generation ensuring that with our gas we
can begin to create industries that will
create major jobs employment for many of
our citizens so we put in case the
industrial nation forecast and we have
created and an industrialization program
where over the next four years who will
be building a major petrochemical plant
nature to major fertilizer plants by
discrete and then comes the LPG
distribution amount
methanol plant this means that my
jeweler will come down tonight for next
week for gas phase industrialization and
the products of that work but it also
means that capacity building imitated
report and high and that the number of
jobs create would never have been seen
before in the oil and gas sector which
is normally very highly capital
intensive and very highly technological
but you also heard about my journal
content palette it was promulgated into
law by as the president in 2010 in the
one and a half years also since it has
been that act has ensured that through
119 years I've been able to get first
consideration it downstream service
sector of the oil and gas industry it
means that over the next five years I
will be keeping in Congress common at
least 10 or 20 billion dollars that was
going out of the country and we need to
bring in service components for the oil
and gas industry so as we speak
fabrication yards i miss tightening lane
application documents and other areas of
the service sector creating continents
for the service sector for sprinting our
print material i doona that all my house
or the service sector surprise are
setting of indigenous businesses to come
into the downstream service sector of
the oil and gas industry which is also a
first for us I think that beyond that
the New York big expanse of what we are
doing LP gas sector without gas based
industries we are trying to ensure that
we support indigenous operators in to
take their place in oil and asset
and I would like to think that Nigeria
for the next five years will with
various and neighbors that we are
putting in place for investors of course
support both in downstream midstream and
off-speed like to come in and partner
with our indigenous marketers and
operators that it will begin to aid not
only destination of choice of oil gas
sector that our and gas sector have
become much more creative and a much
more exciting place for all night in US
but above all that it will begin to
create the 25 dolls that it needs to
create for the economy